now there are seven things in a lot of
foods
that
will ruin your liver and i wanted to
increase your awareness on this because
a lot of people are being exposed to
these things on a regular basis and they
don't know it and as far as your liver
goes you're about as healthy as your
liver your skin is a reflection of the
liver if your liver is bad
your skin's not gonna look too good the
liver is a huge organ it's like three
pounds it helps you with digestion it
helps your blood clot mainly it helps
you detoxify poisons it turns
poisonous things into harmless
things okay and so
let's dive right in and go through the
list number one you want to avoid
soy protein isolates here's a big
question about soy protein isolates
what do you think they do
to isolate this protein from soy
well they use chemicals
it's highly processed
they have to go through a whole series
of things to extract this
concentrated protein and to do that they
have to use something called hexane
that's a petroleum byproduct it's a
solvent it's not good for the liver it's
actually a neurotoxin and so when you
look at like diet shakes or diet powders
or protein bars
or veggie burgers
always read the label
i don't recommend consuming it if it has
soy protein isolates the way i was
introduced to soy protein isolates is
that i had a series of people that came
into my clinic that were on the diet
that was called ideal protein and that
was a major ingredient in this
so-called healthy ketogenic plan where
it had very low carbs but it also had
very very low
fat okay
and very very low quality
ingredients
and so it was filled with soy protein
isolates and i noticed when people got
on that program when they lost weight
and they did lose weight they didn't
look healthy and a number of them
develop serious like liver inflammation
higher amount of liver enzymes
a lot of digestive problems and
gallbladder issues and so when they came
off those products it cleared up they
did much better all right number two uh
fructose okay you have high fructose
corn syrup you have the fructose and
fruit
you have something called agava nectar
as a sweetener it's like 70
uh fructose and even table sugar is half
fructose and half glucose now fructose
is a very interesting sugar because
it's not metabolized by all of your
cells it's only metabolized by your
liver so anytime you consume fructose
your liver has to deal with this sugar
it is stuck to deal with
breaking it down and metabolizing it and
this is why people that consume a lot of
high fructose corn syrup boy they just
develop a fatty liver way more than if
they were going to be consuming just
glucose itself and even uh people think
that agave nectar is so healthy
but it's not because it contains
fructose but here's the confusing thing
fructose on the glycemic index
is pretty low it's like 19. glucose is a
hundred okay so if you have a sugar that
has half glucose and have fructose it's
going to be right in the middle like
about 74 75-ish but the point is that
if you are just relying on the glycemic
index okay that's your
your principle that you operate off of
and you're like wow it's low i'm going
to go ahead and eat it and you don't
understand that the liver has to
metabolize that specific sugar and
indirectly it creates a lot of problems
especially with insulin resistance then
you can have more awareness and then you
can actually
do the right thing by avoiding too much
fructose but the point is that despite
being low on the glycemic index fructose
is not a good sugar especially for the
liver especially if you want to avoid
getting a fatty liver and one more point
about this especially when you're
dealing with high fructose corn syrup
all that corn is gmo and that gives you
another level of toxicity like
glyphosate which is an herbicide that's
not good for the liver instead use sugar
alcohols like erythritol
xylitol use stevia
monk fruit all right number three
vegetable fats now
vegetable fats sound so healthy don't
they i mean they're just the fat of
vegetables well
there's actually not much fat in
vegetables okay
if you look at
salad leafy greens just look at the
nutritional profile and you'll see that
there's not much oil or fat
in vegetables so despite being called
the vegetable oils
it's really grain oils and it's like
bean oils as in soybean oil and i'm
talking about the corn oil the soy oil
canola
cottonseed oil these oils are very
processed they're very oxidating to your
tissues which means they create a lot of
inflammation a lot of inflammation
they're a very fragile oil that's
omega-6 an average person in the u.s
consumes about 70 pounds
of this vegetable oil we've kind of done
a little switch on these oils about
i don't know 30 to 40 years ago where
they switched all of our saturated fats
with unsaturated fats unfortunately so
our membranes now are being built with
this these unsaturated fats and it's
creating a lot of problems with um
inflammation
and um
and then with that comes a lot of other
issues not to mention
gmo okay more glyphosate which is
roundup ready in these products so what
you want to do is you want to consume a
lot more omega-3 fatty acids sardines
cod liver oil salmon things like that
and
just as an fyi
there was a meta-analysis
with over 72 different studies that
showed that there's no
benefit from shifting from saturated
fats to unsaturated fats
zero benefits in fact there's a lot of
negative things that have occurred all
right number four
whey
protein powder now think about what whey
protein powder is it's a protein in milk
and dairy and it's highly concentrated
to be extremely low fat if not zero fat
okay and anytime you
consume something that's refined out of
the normal complex that nature is
designed it comes with a package
and so whey protein is inflammatory it's
a bit toxic to the liver it increases
inflammatory markers and i remember long
ago before i had any awareness on health
i wanted to gain weight okay this was in
high school and so what did i do i
consumed
protein powder and i started chowing
that stuff down and man did i get sick
because not only was it filled with whey
protein powder
it was filled with the next thing on the
list which is
maltodextrin so when you consume protein
make sure you consume it with the with
the fat that's nature has packaged that
protein with but maltodextrin which is
number five
is in so many foods it's crazy it's in
all the protein powders as the first
ingredient sometimes
here's the problem with maltodextrin
it's a synthesized or synthetic sugar
and it is
higher than glucose on the glycemic
index okay it ranges between 110 to 100
and i think 19. it's just off the scale
so you're consuming something that is
way worse than sugar for your blood
sugars for your pancreas for your weight
for your liver
and maltodextrin is put in
a lot of vitamins okay
it's used as a filler it's used as a
drying agent for oils
it's hidden in a lot of so-called
keto-friendly foods which i'm going to
be doing a lot of education about but
basically it makes your liver
fattier
and before i forget i was going to
mention they make
maltodextrin from corn
wheat
rice
potato
tapioca and so sometimes it's going to
be from gmo ingredients but you want to
avoid it they even use it in
post-workout type
gels it's in splenda it's in puddings
it's in protein bars it's in a lot of
different things all right number six
aflotoxins so you want to stop consuming
aflotoxins now what is an aflatoxin well
it's a toxin from a certain fungus which
is carcinogenic to your liver so your
liver does not like this and you're
primarily going to find it in peanuts
and
corn okay
and especially if it's in a moist human
environment now if you consume peanuts
or peanut butter the best way to make
sure you don't get the aflatoxin is by
consuming valencian peanuts valencia
peanuts are a lot drier and they're
usually not going to have
aflotoxins especially if you get organic
valencia peanut butter now of course if
you've been watching my videos you're
you're not going to be consuming
corn
but
corn is in a lot of products so you're
going to have to watch that as well and
number seven
okay is msg monosodium glutamate it's in
a lot of different forms including
modified food starch but you really want
to start reading the ingredients because
they put this in
pork rinds it's in so many foods as a
flavor enhancer they use it in all the
fast fruit restaurants to enhance the
flavor because if it wasn't in there you
wouldn't eat as much but msg causes you
to eat more of it it's definitely in
chinese food and so it's a lot of sodium
that's hidden it's not really salty but
you're going to get fluid retention as
well after you consume it but that's not
the big problem the big problem is toxic
to your liver and it's even in like
things like um
cottage cheese if you're getting like
commercial cottage cheese but i would
just recommend just start reading the
ingredients so many of my patients when
i was in practice
after they complained being sick i just
asked them
when did you start being sick and what
did you eat just before that and there
was usually some ingredient on this list
that they consumed that they weren't
aware they didn't make the connection
now what about red meat is red meat bad
for the liver
well
the answer is if you're consuming
grass-fed red meat it's not bad for the
liver unless
um you have a problem with iron okay the
thing about iron is that our bodies are
not designed to get rid of iron easily
and too much iron
can be very toxic to the liver and even
cause cirrhosis and of course red meat
is high in iron
so
if you have that problem then you're
probably going to have to avoid red meat
but
for most people that don't have a
problem with that red meat is not going
to be a problem for your liver if it's
quality out of all the foods that are
good for the liver the cruciferous
family of vegetables are the best thing
for the liver so that would be like
arugula the kale the broccoli the
brussels sprouts so you definitely want
to consume those on a regular basis now
that you have this information
the next video that i'm going to
recommend is what to consume or what to
do
to repair a liver
i put it right here check it out
you